hi I'm Jane Fonda and I'm telling you I
am so
really deeply happy and excited to be
sitting opposite Conan for a
conversation I'm a huge fan oh wow okay
well this oh boy that's that's true well
I can't handle that and you know why I
can't handle that because when I was a
young lad my dad took me to a movie
theater that was showing uh sort of a
Revival house it was Coolidge Corner in
Brookline Massachusetts Brookline and
Brookline Mass and I went there and I
saw cat blue oh and fell in love with
you oh good completely head over heels
in love with you I like that oh oh and
then well then it just keep then I I
mean I think I didn't see I should stop
there
it doesn't get better than that well it
does because then I think I know this
isn't chronological but I was seeing
these films a little later on I saw
Barefoot in the Park and I remembered
thinking that's who I want to marry I
want to marry Jane Fonda because I saw
you as this new newlywed and Barefoot in
the Park and I just are you about to
propose yes yes I am I have a ring I've
talked it over with my wife and by the
way my wife if I called her up and I
said I'm leaving you for another woman
and it's Jane fun and she would say go
for it
because she adores you as well so I
could become one of those women who has
a husband that could be her son
well uh yeah I suppose I suppose no you
could be my son yeah but you know
whatever that's cool that's cool yeah
yeah I mean look I'm sure I'll
disappoint you in many ways
um but let's not even get into that I
love tall men oh and you know and I
didn't really realize for a long time
how tall you are how tall are you I'm
six four oh God it's beautiful this is
happening this is happening right now
someone sent out for some wine Prime
Time Eduardo get some wine in here
Prosecco Prosecco something you got it
oh my God I'm just in heaven but I I
don't know can I say yeah I am so happy
for you
that you are doing this podcast and not
having to do a show oh thank you yeah
it's liberating it gives you a life you
don't have to worry about hair
it's great no I almost didn't bring my
wig in today I almost didn't do it it's
funny you say that because you came on
The Late Night show one time and we had
you were terrific it's 2014 but we
couldn't talk like this no there's a bed
and there's I mean there's an audience
and I loved doing that and they did it
for almost 30 years but what I've Loved
about this is I knew that you were
coming in and I was excited because I
thought there's so much we can talk
about and in an intimate environment you
know and I think if I had told you how
much I loved you and wanted to marry you
as a child in front of an audience you
know someone's going to intervene
someone's going to step in the way and
say but here uh no one right we should
have you should have you should have
stopped
but thank you I'm honored that you felt
that way you feel that way
um but there's so much to talk about I
was mentioning to you just as you walked
in
I used to live on a street called Tiger
Tail and there was an older gentleman
that lived on Tiger Tail when I first
moved there about I want to say 12 years
ago and this Old Gentleman said you know
when I first moved to Tiger Tail I used
to see you know Jane Fonda riding up
this road on a horse on our way back
from school and I thought poor old man
he's lost his mind no I used to ride a
horse to school it wasn't my horse it
was the school's horse
was it painted yellow
and they had a little stop sign that
came out every time
they would loan it out to a few of us
who were good Riders wow so you would
ride home and this is here in Los
Angeles on the West Side override down
Tiger Tail Road down Cantor to San
Vicente and what is now that centerpiece
that has those huge Coral trees yeah
that was the trolley tracks that's right
and it was also a bridal path and I
could ride that down to school which was
on the corner of San Vicente and 26th
Street that's unbelievable I know so you
were basically growing up in Los Angeles
but it could have been 1855 the way you
were getting to school uh yeah if you
didn't pay attention to the cars that
were coming
you know right
it's wonderful to have been alive in the
late 30s and 40s
the world had only 2 billion people and
that affected every nook and cranny of
Life there were more birds there were
more empty spaces that a boy or a girl
could explore and play in I mean we
lived at the end of a dirt road at that
time I mean you can't there's so many
houses where we used to live now I can't
even hardly find it but where you live
is the canyon in front of the nine acres
where we had a farmhouse it's
unbelievable you had nine acres up there
and now it's all been developed there's
about 20 houses on that piece of
property I can't even as we talked about
before the show started you know it's
the first house that you live in is the
one in your dreams right that house that
land at the top of a hill overlooking
the Pacific Ocean during the second
world war when we used to have remember
well no you don't remember it was the
second world war had started then there
were blackouts and we had to you know
hide under tables during air raid drills
drills and things like that and so
that's very much in my dream it's
unbelievable yeah because I can't find
it Well I will find out where the house
was and my promise to you is I will I
will find a way to buy all those homes
raise them to the ground and I will
restore your Ranch the two of you will
live and we're gonna get married
I don't want to get married again see my
dad was married five times I've only
been married three times and I don't
want to add to that so we'll live in sin
this is the greatest day of my life this
is the best day I've ever had in my life
I find that can be your side piece so
you could still you could still be
married
call Elijah you deal with it oh man
you're my assistant you deal with it
I'm going out on a limb here I assume
that you're married and Liza is your
wife yes yes you are yeah you're going
way out on a limb but yeah 21 years
we've been married yeah okay well maybe
I won't call her maybe we could do a
threesome
[Laughter]
okay yes I can